new york father pulls his daughter out
of brearly
with a message to the whole school is
the damn starting to break
yeah i have not read the letter i'm
aware of it um
certainly in the last month or two um
from from what i've seen largely through
the efforts of barry weiss
and um caitlyn flanagan
um we this
the problems with the wokeness in the
elite private schools in particular
elite private um secondary schools is
coming to a head is becoming really uh
well known in some circles
that said the rhetoric that we see
in other places looks unchanged
um as if as if that's not happening
at all so i don't know i don't know what
it takes
i know that um
gosh i think it was
fall of 2019 that james lindsey
said that he thought it was happening
damn was breaking people were becoming
aware of it
it's like i don't think so man like i
think
i i just i don't think it's where you
think it is
and of course it didn't yeah you know it
only continued to get worse
um so you know there have been a lot of
these moments
um and i i guess i don't want to get my
hopes up
well here's a frightening prospect i
agree with you the chances that
we've hit bottom it always seems like we
might have and then things just get
stupider but
um imagine that the elite schools
wake up and the parents who get it
you know and there are likely to be many
uh
successfully fight back and then
once again we have another version of
this trick
that involves the distinction between
private schools and public schools
right where we underfund the public
schools
those who can afford to send their kids
to private schools don't suffer from
having hobbled their kids in bad public
schools
and it creates a self-reinforcing
pattern
of the distribution of opportunity that
nobody needs to
uh own up to having created in other
words sabotage the public schools
um privately subsidize the private
schools so that they're better
and the point is what is that that's the
wealthy hobbling other people's children
so they can't compete
yeah um i mean it's it's kind of the
opposite at the moment like the private
schools are worse
but imagine that they come to their
senses and suddenly the only schools
that aren't insane
are elite private schools right one can
easily imagine that world because we've
lived in it
i guess um i i i mean i guess i'm not
sure why we're imagining
the world that is the inverse of the one
we're in right now which is plenty bad
enough
and um because wealthy people
have the means to erect their own system
if they need to
and that in effect
seeing a novel version of an old game
would not be surprising
something that will need to happen um so
it was
it was a father right that pulled his
daughter out
um that wrote this letter and pulled it
out and i think um
the damn is gonna have to break with the
mothers
if that's gonna happen and you know
you're imagining that this amazing thing
happens and then it becomes
yet another reinforcement of class
privilege
rather than talk about the damn having
the amazing thing having happened and
then
one of the possible immediate after
effects
i think for that damned break um
the the tougher parent in most
situations
to see this ideology for what it is and
to resist it
and to be disagreeable and to stand up
to it and to say
i don't think so not for me of course i
care about black people
this is really uncomfortable why did i
just lose all my friends
is gonna it's gonna be mothers and um
i think you know so far many of the
examples
um we're seeing like barry weiss posted
a piece written by a teacher at an elite
school on the east coast
this week who's standing up to this a
male teacher you know and
these are anecdotes but i think what we
what we need for the dam to break is for
more
for more women to stand up and say
actually i'm going to change
the um the expectation in the community
that we don't do this
that this is actually this thing that we
are all on board with is actually the
diabolical thing
um because that's it's it's much
it's just going to be necessary if
things are going to change yeah
so actually it's i think you're making a
very important point
um this i mean this is apropos
as you know and i think i mentioned
maybe last week and i've been i i've
been asked to write this
commentary on a piece on um
historical relationships between women
and men and women and men and all this
but
like deep historical relationships
between women and how it affects
relationships today and i've been
thinking about the different kinds of
competition that men engage in
yeah and that women engage in and what
that looks like when men and women
interact
and and how much we pretend that those
that that deep history doesn't exist
back when and um and and to to
in our to our peril right and so so much
of the literature
is just insanely stupidly written the
scientific literature of course because
it always is it says things like well
women
don't compete women say they don't like
to compete therefore they don't compete
women when asked to engage in this you
know
doodly competitive thing said they
didn't want to play therefore women
don't compete it's like
oh my god like of course women compete
women compete all the time just as much
as men
but um but differently and and you know
in a word
it tends to be that men tend to compete
overtly and women tend to compete
covertly and there are so many
downstream effects of this
that are that are so important that it
will also be and this is something i
think this is
new i think no one has said this before
will also be harder to opt
out of covert than overt games
than covert than over competition
because as a man you can like
say yep not playing and you might get
chided for it you might get shamed for
it but everyone knows he's not playing
he's doing
something different right and if the
competition is covert
it's all behind the back and it's gossip
and it's sidelining and it's social and
you know like you can't just say like
i'm not playing yeah
you're like oh yes you are we're not
going to let you not play
so she's not playing oh that's a really
good move
and sometimes it will be yeah right
sometimes sometimes that is a that is
a move actually so anyway like i'm
wrapped up in this
in this space anyway but i in order for
this damn to break we need
women who are somewhat dominant in
whatever little social hierarchies
they're in
at these schools to actually make the
moves to make it
you know to make it the desirable
position to be standing up to this
because until that happens those few
dads who stand up and do it
are you know are are not going to make
the difference i don't think
so i think i just want to put three
things on the list here you've mentioned
disagreeableness which is more common
exactly i did so intentionally right
this is a necessary skill to say no in
the face of something like this
there is the question of compassion this
movement hijacks compassion
and compassion compassion is going to be
more easily hijacked in women very
likely it's probably a more
uh more intensely developed skill the
nature of being female being one that
requires this
you know more directly for mothering for
example
right um and then there's the question
about this distinction between males and
females in terms
of the preferences for the types of
things they engage in and
so the classic way to describe it is
people versus things where men tend to
be more interested in things women tend
to be more interested in people
and the thing is people is a
yeah the thing is i said it i said it
because i'm masculine
no the thing is that the world of things
is a world of conservation laws that is
unforgiving
right and so the world of conservation
laws is one
in which one discovers that certain
that an illogical system does not
function right
a world of people does not necessarily
have conservation laws in the same sense
and so there's a question about
um whether there is a a gender split
here that might be setting us up for
disaster yeah
don't don't feel like you have to cut it
short i just have you know about eight
things to say
in response you know so there's we have
talked about you know being spending
understanding something about the
physical world as opposed to being
entirely based in the social world
and that you know that does map somewhat
onto things versus people
and so given that it is a you know
well-replicated psychological finding
that men are and you know including
babies including other cultures right
like
more interested in things on average
tendency and women in people and animals
right
that that would also suggest that
many women have more of their entire
life invested
in the relationships that they have and
so it actually comes at a cost to more
a higher percentage of their life to go
against the crowd whereas men if they're
engaged with these things that actually
are meaningful to them they can go to
their damn shop
be like okay well i stood up to that now
i get to tinker you know whatever it is
it's a caricature but it's not your
whole world it's not your entire world
collapsing
um so they're just you know i haven't
actually found
even the typical character trait by by
gender that goes against this model like
it all just like
falls which which makes it you know this
is the one of the few things i'm like
god
did someone really smart devise this to
you know capture women and then take out
a whole society because this seems so
deviously perfect to to prey on
many of the best characteristics of
women and turn them into the worst
characteristics for society
yeah um i mean it's hard to even say
these things out loud but at some level
this does
you know the whole um
the whole woke ideology feels like it
has dragged civilization
into the dynamics of a uh
a dysfunctional merit right it feels
i mean it just does and um yeah
i mean i i don't like saying it on the
other hand it's not like everything
isn't at stake we're actually
talking about you know the dumbest
policy proposals one could conceive of
and yet we are entertaining them because
nobody's in a position to say
actually you can't abolish the police
here's why end of story right that's
what you need to say
right sorry boston police not on the
table here's why
um so anyway yeah um
we need we need we need more
disagreeable women
on it all right
[Laughter]
you can only be one disagreeable woman
you